LOUIS GRAY: Welcome back to
Google Developers Live at I/O.
Louis Gray here with
Daniel Sieberg.
DANIEL SIEBERG: That's right.
And one of the big mentions of
the keynote yesterday was, of
course, Google Maps.
We saw a lot of big updates
and refreshes.
And so yesterday, I
got a chance to go
to the Sandbox here.
Some amazing stuff going on.
I think it's fascinating what
people are doing tying into
the Maps API.
LOUIS GRAY: We're short on time
before the next session.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Yes, we are.
LOUIS GRAY: So what we're going
to do is we're going to
right to that interview
that took place
with the Sandbox yesterday.
Let's go ahead and
roll that video.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
DANIEL SIEBERG: Hi there.
I'm Daniel Sieberg with
Google Developers
Live here at I/O 2013.
We find ourselves in the Maps
Sandbox, and I'm joined right
now by Mano Marks, who
is a Lead Developer
Advocate on the Maps team.
We're going be talking about
Nintendo's Wii Street U. So I
want you to walk us through what
this is all about, and
obviously bring in Ryan
here for Nintendo.
MANO MARKS: Sure.
So hi.
I'm Mano.
This is Ryan Lund from Nintendo
showing off the Wii
U, which has a great new Street
View application using
the Wii U and the Wii
U controller.
So do you want to walk
us through it?
RYAN LUND: Yes, please.
Thank you, Mano.
So what we have here is we
have Wii Street View.
This is a free application
available on the
Nintendo Wii U console.
You can download it today
from the Free Shop.
And what it is, it's an
application written in HTML5
and JavaScript using the
Nintendo web framework, and
that allowed us to really wrap
and reiterate on this
application, as well as use the
great Google Maps APIs to
bring in the Maps data and
really make it a very
interactive experience with
the Wii Street U and the
Street View data.
So I'm just going to walk you
through this application a
little bit.
So what we have is first thing
is I'm going to take you on a
tour, and so I'm going to load
up on the game pad here some
recommended spots, and we're
going to go ahead and jump
over to Florence, Italy.
And what you can see down here
on the game pad is that I can
navigate the Street View
information very naturally
with the gyroscope information
from the game pad controller.
And you can see that we have
really smooth motion.
I can go ahead and start
navigating down
this Italian street.
And all of this information is
stored in the Google Maps
servers, and it's really great
that when we designed and
worked with this application,
we had all of this content
available to us, all of these
really good imagery that we
could just put and interface
on top of.
One of the new features that
we just enabled in the
application is integration
with Wiiverse, which is
Nintendo's social platform.
So I'm going to go ahead
and give you a
demonstration of that.
So this allows you to, when you
find a location or a spot
that's really interesting, you
can flag it and upload it to
the Miiverse servers and share
it with your friends or share
it with the community
so that they can
find those spots later.
So I'm going to select Latest
Posts, and these are posts
that have been shared live by
users of Wii Street View now.
DANIEL SIEBERG: So Mano, talk
to me a little bit about
working with Nintendo,
what that was like.
This is a very unique way of
seeing the Street View imagery
through a gaming console.
MANO MARKS: It was a really
exciting partnership because
their platform is based on web,
so they're actually using
the JavaScript APIs
to build this.
So this is something,
theoretically, that anybody
who had their own platform and
the right licenses could do
using the Google Maps API.
It's really an inspiring use,
and I love to see the
coordination between the
different devices there.
So you've got the controller
and the Wii itself
displaying up here.
It's a really great
implementation.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Great.
I just want to know when Mario
is going to show up in one of
the Street View scenes.
RYAN LUND: We take feature
requests, but I can't promise
that we'll get him in.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Cool.
Great.
Thank you so much.
MANO MARKS: Thanks a lot.
RYAN LUND: Thank you.
DANIEL SIEBERG: All right.
We're going to dive into
our next partner now.
In fact, we're going to map dive
into our next partner.
This is a new term that
I'm learning here.
Mano joins me again, and
Ben from Instrument.
So Mano, talk to me a little
bit about what we're
seeing behind us.
I know that these are familiar
to Googlers, this Liquid
Galaxy Display, but this is a
unique way of presenting it.
MANO MARKS: So Liquid
Galaxy is actually a
collection of hardware.
We actually open source the
plans on how to build this, so
anybody could theoretically
build this as long as they're
willing to invest
in the hardware.
And it's a way of getting a
bunch of different computers
and screens to synchronize
together so you can do this
kind of large scale display.
And the instrument folks have
done a great application
called Google Map Dive--
and you can actually see this
in the background--
and this is all using HTML5
and the JavaScript API.
So why don't you tell us a
little bit more about it?
BEN PURDY: All right.
So what you're seeing behind
me here is all running in
Google Chrome.
We've got seven separate
instances of Chrome each
running on a separate PC, and
they're all being synchronized
through web sockets.
The game itself is running on
an additional machine that's
hidden behind these displays
here, and it's sort of keeping
track of the game state and then
broadcasting that out to
all seven of the display
nodes over web sockets.
And so the 3D game content
that you can see the
foreground is a WebGL layer with
a transparent background,
and behind that, we have a live
HTML Google Maps region
that is transformed
using 3D CSS.
And so using 3.JS, we're able
to synchronize the camera
between the WebGL view and the
3D CSS view, and so what we
get is this really
cohesive scene.
We're able to stitch the image
between all seven monitors
just by offsetting the camera
between each display.
DANIEL SIEBERG: So this is
an entirely accurate
representation of Google Maps?
BEN PURDY: Yeah, you're seeing
a live Google Map.
MANO MARKS: Yeah.
And in fact, the first question
a lot of people ask
you is, is this term
compliant?
BEN PURDY: Yes, it is
term complaint.
We're not accessing
tiles directly.
If I hadn't turned off the User
Interface Events, you'd
be able to drag that map around
if you had a mouse.
So the reason it looks a little
nontraditional is that
we've used the Styling API
extensively to create these
custom themes for each of the
maps, but it is an actual
Google Map.
The way we're doing the
sky haze, that kind
of causes some suspicion.
That's an OpenGL layer in the
WebGL view that's simply
fading from transparent to the
sky color that we've chosen.
And that way, we hide the hard
edges of the corners.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Clearly this is
a lot of fun and a lot of
people like us would like
it in their living room.
What's the future of this?
Where is it going?
BEN PURDY: Well, our plan right
now is to clean up the
code a little bit and
get it running in a
single browser instance.
Right now, it's sort of
distributed where we have the
server and the client separate
and talking over web sockets.
But we're going to do some
refactoring and get it running
in a single browser window, and
then we'd like to release
it and open source it and maybe
put it up on Chrome
Experiments or something
like that.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Where does this
rank in the uniqueness of
what some of the partners
are doing?
This seems pretty awesome.
MANO MARKS: This is
pretty high up.
We've got a really great
sandbox this year.
This is pretty amazing,
pretty impressive.
Really, really great
to see this.
BEN PURDY: I don't know if
you're watching this remotely,
but if you are here somewhere,
you should come and play it.
It's a lot of fun.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Exactly.
All right, cool.
Ben, thank you so much.
BEN PURDY: Sure.
Appreciate it.
MANO MARKS: Thanks, Ben.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Well, I forgot
that I loaned my car out to do
this next demo, I wish.
We're actually over at the
Mercedes Benz part of the Map
Sandbox, and I'm joined now by
Chris from Mercedes Benz to
talk about some really cool
navigation features that are
built into this car.
First of all, what are we
sitting in right now?
CHRIS BUSENBARK: So right
now, this is an SL 550.
It's a pretty payment, so--
DANIEL SIEBERG: Yeah.
It's on the wish list.
CHRIS BUSENBARK: It's
on the wish list.
LOUIS GRAY: So tell me about
this screen that we're looking
at right here and
what it can do.
CHRIS BUSENBARK: So this current
screen, we want to
show off our Google APIs that
we've implemented in this app.
All this right now is powered
by a smartphone.
All the cellular data, all the
network requests are going
over the cellular data.
So we basically just
use this head unit
just for drawing stuff.
So this place is powered by
Google Tile that we have here.
What it does is it takes away
the tedious address entry of
enter in your city, enter in
your state, enter in your
house number.
So what we can do here is we
can select this tile and we
can set a destination.
So for example, let's just type
in "8", like we want to
go to 88 Howard.
So what we do, we type in "8"
and it autocompletes each time
we type in a letter, and this
takes away us having to enter
in the location, the city, the
street, and all that stuff.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Right.
And all of this is being
done with this--
what do you want to call it,
jog wheel down here?
CHRIS BUSENBARK: Right.
We call it a CCE, but rotary
knob, whatever you
want to call it.
So we can just type in a random
address, so let's do
like five, six, and
56th Street
DANIEL SIEBERG: So it's already
suggesting ones that
would [INAUDIBLE].
CHRIS BUSENBARK: Correct.
So 562 Sutter Street.
We can select this, and now what
we can do is we can view
Street View of this location.
And now since we have a rotary
knob here, what we can do is
do a whole 360 degrees of the
Street View, which allows for
a very intuitive kind
of experience.
DANIEL SIEBERG: So you can
really see, before you even
get there, what to expect.
CHRIS BUSENBARK: Correct.
It's just an awesome feature.
It really helps to be able to
quickly go through the tiles
that are returned.
Another feature we have is
the View All Map feature.
So this uses the Google Maps
SDK, and what it does is
allows you to see the general
area of the PoI.
So you can zoom out,
you can zoom in.
If you zoom in far enough, you
get the pretty little 3D
buildings that makes it-- ooh.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Sure, sure,
just like you would on a
device, a mobile device.
CHRIS BUSENBARK: Exactly.
So this gives you a general
idea of where stuff is.
So this search can also
handle categories.
So what we can do is we can
search general pizza.
So this will actually return
us results of all the pizza
places that are currently
around us.
It gives us the star rating that
is returned, the price,
and the distance from us.
So for example, we'll select
this pizza place and it gives
us a couple more details such
as when it's opened, and we
can actually call the place
too if we wanted to
preorder our pizza.
It gives us the same features.
It has Street View in it,
viewing it on the map.
And also, photos.
DANIEL SIEBERG: User
generated photos?
CHRIS BUSENBARK: So these are
user generated photos that are
uploaded to Google.
Someone had a very good green
onion pizza here.
And you can just scroll through
them just to see if
you want to go to that place.
And that covers our Autocomplete
feature.
Another feature we want to
highlight on is our Traffic.
This also uses the
Google Maps SDK.
It's just like your typical
experience when you're looking
at Google Traffic on the
web or the browser.
You know what the
color lines are.
While you're driving, you can
pan around, see what the
traffic is on the bridge, zoom
in on the bridge just in case
you don't see the right color.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Doesn't look
too bad right now.
CHRIS BUSENBARK: Doesn't
look too bad.
It will later, right?
Everyone's going home.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Let's move on.
We've just got a little time
left if you can show us the
last feature.
CHRIS BUSENBARK: So the last
thing is a City Guide.
So what this is, it allows you
just to view a variety of
categories around you.
So you can say, I want to know
the nightlife around me.
And so you can select this,
and it returns basically--
as you know a weather
map, green means
light, red means heavy.
In this case, white
means heavy.
So you know underneath that
white little area, there's a
lot of night life and
so you can go there.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Cool.
All right.
Put your seat belts on.
We are out of here.
CHRIS BUSENBARK: We're
out of here.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Thank
you so much, Chris.
That's going to do it for here
at the Maps Sandbox with
Google Developers Live.
Stay tuned for lots more
content right here.
I think I'm going to become
a professional
map diver after that.
And just a quick shout out.
If you want to check out the new
Google Maps, remember to
go to maps.google.com/preview
and sign up.
LOUIS GRAY: Great.
Thanks for the preview.
We'll be right back at 2:20
to talk Chromebook Pixel.
Enjoy your sessions.